it's great to welcome to the program
today tom standage who is deputy editor
of the economist and also author of the
book a brief history of motion from the
wheel to the car to what comes next uh
tom it's great to have you on today
really appreciate it thanks very much
for having me you know i've uh i'm
actually reading right now the book
1491.
and uh one of the interesting anecdotes
in it is about how was it that so few
spaniards were able to defeat these
these large armies of uh of inca and
other groups in what is now central
america and one of the things that's
mentioned was the superior uh
understanding and use of the wheel in
all of its different forms by by the
spanish and although i wasn't reading
that because i was going to be
interviewing you it i think the
importance of the wheel and ultimately
of automobiles it really cannot be
overstated in terms of its impact on
human society and culture can it well i
think that's true but i also think it's
very easy to overlook um so for example
someone once said that if you're a fish
right you're swimming around in water
all the time but fish have no concept of
what water is because they're just
surrounded by it they just assume that's
you know that's the way the world is um
and i think we're sort of the same with
cars we we live in a world that has been
shaped by cars and we can't imagine it
really being any other way so what i'm
trying to do with this book is sort of
point out the water to the fish and say
how did we get here and how might things
look different and um if we are going to
be less reliant on cars in the future
and i think we probably are um then you
know it's helpful to see if we're going
to start unpicking cars from the fabric
of our civilization and from everyday
life then it's useful to see how it was
woven in so that's really what i'm what
i'm trying to do in 1491 the other
factor we should mention of course was
disease i mean the fact that indeed the
europeans took all those contagious i'm
sure the wheel played a role the other
interesting thing is that american
cultures were aware of the wheel um but
generally didn't use it um it was uh it
was used in some toys uh and this is one
of the striking things you know the
wheel is a great cliche uh about the
wheel is it's well the greatest
invention it's in history and this sort
of thing um but the amazing thing is how
many cultures knew about it but didn't
use it another example would be the
egyptians who managed to build the
pyramids entirely without using wheels
uh they knew about wheels because the
mesopotamians next door had them but the
the egyptians just found it much easier
to move things around them rafts on the
nile and rollers and the fact there was
no wheeled vehicle on earth that could
have taken a a block that you would use
to build the pyramid it was just those
pyramid blocks are really really big and
heavy so um so this idea that wheels are
the greatest thing ever is a very recent
idea it's a sort of early 20th century
idea and it's at the point where we're
reshaping the world around wheeled
vehicles that we decide that actually
wheels are totally awesome um but that's
a relatively recent way of looking at
things yeah i uh
i think sometimes it's missed by lots of
people
that in cities towns villages i mean in
much of what is when i say the developed
world i don't even mean the west but
just even parts of any country that is
what we would consider
developed at all
the um amount of uh the planning and and
surface area
that is geared around
prioritizing wheeled vehicles over
walking and and that unless you think
about it it may not be apparent to many
people no well i mean it's it's more of
it's obviously most most recognizable in
in the us which has these laws about you
know if you build a new retail
development you have to have a certain
number of car parking spaces right by
one estimate there's six parking spaces
i think for every car in the u.s
um so i mean that's at about 30 of the
area of a typical u.s city is parking um
so i mean it's it's amazing how much
space is is um is given over to vehicles
and i think one of the interesting
stories um that i really you know found
uh i was struck by when i was
researching the book was the extent to
which um you know this this handing over
of so much space to the car is a very
recent thing it's only happened in the
past hundred years i mean even if you
look at photographs of streets from say
1910 in europe and the us um you don't
see parked cars along the side of the
street um and then and you also see if
you look at film from the early 20th
century there's a very famous film of um
uh going down san francisco
in about i think it's you know first
decade in the 20th century it's just
before the big earthquake and um
uh and it's amazing that you've got all
these different kinds of vehicles and
people you know weaving in and out of
each other yeah um and then in the 1920s
you get this big change where they the
car drivers say well no this is slowing
us down everyone else needs to get out
of the way roads are for cars they're
definitely not for pedestrians they're
definitely not for horse draw vehicles
frankly we don't much like street cars
either because they get in the way um
and so the supremacy of the car really
becomes a thing at that point and you
know nowadays you know if you stand in
the middle of the road you're an idiot a
car's going to hit you of course it is
what are you doing there um but that's
not the way streets used to work and
again this is something that we sort of
take for granted if we've grown up in a
world that's full of cars um but that's
not the way things were and it's you
know not the way things have to be and
if you go to some parts of the world
it's not like that and you do have much
more of a sort of you know sharing of
street space and similarly even some
western countries have decided to take
back some of that space from cars we've
seen a lot of this in the pandemic but
it was already happening in places like
oslo and helsinki where quite a lot of
the city center you know spaces car
parking was given given to bike lanes
areas pedestrianized and so on so i
think we're trying to sort of rediscover
what a less car centric world would look
like
yeah and i think one of the there's this
kind of uh i don't know if it's a it's
not really a thought experiment there's
this line that's often mentioned about
you know humans don't really know what
comes next and what the next advancement
would be because if you asked the horse
and buggy people right before cars came
to be what they wanted for better
transportation they would say a more
reliable or a faster horse and buggy
which means they missed the possible
paradigm shift of cars
with that as a kind of framework
when we talk about electric vehicles
when we talk about self-driving
etc
do you think that we're even really
talking about what the next paradigm
shifts will be in wheeled transportation
or or is it more likely about well i
think i think we're in danger of falling
into a historical trap so this book you
know it tells the story of wheeled
vehicles starting with the first wheels
and then looking at you know
various attempts to make steam-powered
vehicles and trains and bicycles and
then you get to cars and cars kind of
take over um and then i try to look at
what's coming next but i start the book
and the reason i think this this whole
history is worth looking at so much now
by comparing the current situation with
the situation in the 1890s and in the
1890s it was it was becoming apparent
that the dependency that big
fast-growing cities had on the horse and
horse-based transport was completely
unsustainable so the population of
horses in places like london and new
york was growing much faster than the
population of people and more and more
horses per person were needed to move
goods and people around and railways
made it worse because you have more
goods and people coming in and out of
cities
and so the more you have those
long-distance links the more you need
capacity within the city to move people
and goods around and so this was
becoming you know recognized as a big
problem there was more and more horse
manure piling up in the streets it was a
big pollution problem it was a big
health problem there were lots and lots
of traffic jams it was very very noisy
um there were accidents and so on and so
on and so people were
they realized this was unsustainable but
they weren't sure what was going to come
next and then the the automobile is
invented at around this time it's you
know it's been in the works for actually
about you know
a century or longer depending on how you
look at it but um
the the proponents of the automobile say
it's going to solve these problems
you're not going to have horsemen you're
you're not going to have traffic because
taking away the the horse they're
originally called horseless carriages
will mean that these vehicles take up
less space on the street so they can
move faster
they're not going to make as much noise
because they've got rubber tires so
streets are going to be much quieter and
there aren't going to be any accidents
because you haven't got horses to kind
of kick people or or run away and um of
course all of these predictions turn out
to be wrong and we get more traffic and
more noise and more accidents and the
pollution is not so visible but it's
still just as problematic in the form of
particulates and um and carbon dioxide
but what's interesting is that the
original way that this is portrayed is
as horseless carriages in other words
it's in a negative way so we take away
the horse and our problems go away and
now a century later we've a bit more
than a century we've recognized that um
that our car based um transport system
is also unsustainable for environmental
reasons and again there's this sort of
you know apparently simple fix which is
fine we just make everything electric or
we make everything driverless and then
you know we've kind of fixed it um and i
think we the risk is that we fall into
the trap of of like you know if we just
change that one thing everything else
will stay the same and the the story of
the cast shows you that that's not the
case because changing from horse drawn
to
vehicles to cars
had all of these unexpected consequences
and i'm sure the same would be true if
we tried to just apply one of these
fixes so what i'm really arguing for in
this book what i think is going to
happen is that we're going to have less
of a monoculture in urban transport when
we had a monoculture based on
horse-drawn vehicles then we have in
many parts of the world of monoculture
based on on cars and i think what we're
moving towards in the future is much
more of a mixture of modes of transport
so not just buses and public transport
but things like bike red rental
ride hailing scooters um cycle lanes
more walking i mean just all of these
things and i call this the internet of
motion and the reason i think this is
kind of a much more feasible alternative
to to using cars for everything than it
used to be is because of the smartphone
and what the smartphone allows you to do
is knit together all of these different
transport modes so you can say to your
phone i want to go from here to here and
it will say well there's a bus arriving
in two minutes at the end of the street
so take that and then get off and then
you know get onto
i don't know a scooter or or a ride hail
or something like that but you can
actually integrate all these forms of
transport in ways that you couldn't
before we had smartphones so in that
sense the successor to the car and car
based sort of transport culture is the
smartphone but it's because it allows
you to combine all these other things so
yeah i think the idea that we just kind
of haven't got to go on the way we are
now but with electric motors instead of
internal combustion engines i think is
is simplistic and i think it's wrong
one of the things that i'm curious to
get your thoughts on is that both when
it comes to automobile travel
uh and air travel it's sort of been a
while since there's been a real paradigm
shift in it getting significantly faster
now i don't think the most important
thing is speed and there's this
obsession with speed and efficiency but
i think it's it's an interesting topic
which is
um when you consider
you know okay vehicles today may have a
higher top speed than they had 50 years
ago but due to congestion and due to so
many other things your effective
traveling speed in a vehicle is not
dramatically faster than when the
highways were first built that was a big
advancement highway speed as it was in
the 1890s it's eight miles an hour so it
hasn't changed at all
right
right
when it comes to air travel we had this
phase where you had the concorde
supersonic but it was
very expensive and inefficient and loud
and now united airlines has committed
again to supersonic but basically you
know planes have basically been going
550 miles an hour for a very long time
now and it seems out of sync with the
dramatic advancement in so many other
areas computer processing speed etc what
do you make of that um i think it's a
logistical thing so if you look at the
era when when concord was running so
concord could basically do um london to
jfk in
what something like three hours right
instead of instead of six or seven um
so but if you actually if if you're
somewhere in london so here i live in on
the other side of london to east london
um so it would take you so at best it
would take me an hour to get to heathrow
airport and i probably should allow two
um and then obviously i have to check in
two hours before the flight
and i've got to go through security and
all that kind of stuff so basically i
have to leave four hours before the
plane takes off then when i get to jfk i
have to stand in line maybe for a couple
of hours to get through immigration um i
mean
right but it has been i mean it varies
you know even if you've even if you're
flying at the front of the plane you get
off the plane there you you know if
another plane's come in then there may
be a there may be a lot of q you may
have to wait for your luggage then you
have to get into manhattan which is
again you find a cab and um i mean i
like i tend not to take a cab because it
makes me feel ill so i prefer to take
the air train in the subway but again
that takes you an hour to get to the you
know to the to the um to midtown um so
so again you're you're looking at
basically a whatever that is
12 15 hour process and concord takes
kind of four hours off the middle bit
but it's right that's not really
affecting the given how much more
expensive it is it's not really
affecting the overall
um
door-to-door travel time that much and
so the number of people who are prepared
to pay
you know that much more money to just
take a take three or four hours off the
middle of a 12-hour process was not big
enough to make it work and we'll see
what happens with this new generation of
supersonic planes but i mean you know
the i mean you can't fly supersonic over
land and so they're trying to come up
with various you know fixes for that but
um if there's one route in the world it
was going to work on it would be london
jfk and that was the route that you know
concord was was most effective on and it
just it didn't add up so so yeah i think
the thing to watch out for here and i
don't go into this in the book because
it's um it's you know not about wheels
and um but it's this idea of sub-orbital
transport and this is something that uh
elon musk has talked about i mean people
have talked about this for ages but he's
actually building a vehicle now that um
that may even fly in the next few weeks
that we might see doing this um and this
is where you basically launch a rocket
but instead of going into orbit uh so to
get it if you go into orbit if the space
station orbits about once every 90
minutes so if you get into the lowest
possible earth orbit um you're going
around the world once every 90 minutes
and another way of looking at that is if
you launch yourself into an orbit that
doesn't quite
um it doesn't quite make it into orbit
so it's just sub-orbital and then comes
down on the other side of the world
you'll get there you know in 45 minutes
to an hour so this is the idea that you
could fly from pretty much anywhere to
anywhere in less than an hour if you
took a sub-orbital trajectory and the
starship may be able to do that then
you've got this big problem again if you
have to build space ports outside cities
and musk is talking about floating space
ports and so so that's that's a
potential um you know game changer in
terms of uh uh of those things but i
think we're still going to come back to
you know i like to say even if we build
hyperspace tunnels from you know from
london to new york you're still going to
have to have security around them you're
still going to have limited capacity and
you're still going to have to go to the
hyperspace port which is probably on the
other side of town so then you then
you're london to jfk you know london to
new york you know maybe you can maybe
you can take a few hours out of it again
but you're still not getting it down to
zero and you can have that technology in
everyone's homes and you can like step
through your
your hyperspace port into your holiday
home in another country then you know i
can't see that that can't see that
working and we don't even know if this
is possible so so yeah i think it's a
very good point that actually these
boring logistical constraints actually
um end up being the most important
factor we've been
speaking with the books author tom
standish who's deputy editor of the
economist tom really a pleasure speaking
with you today i appreciate it
thank you thanks for having me